alors nous aussi nous sommes très fiers
puisque aujourd'hui on a rencontré une
grande grande star et ouais le comédien
Pierre Richard qui est de passage en
Touren ce jeudi il joue son spectacle
musical au nouvel atrium de
Saint-Avertin et il a accordé on en est
très content une interview et un
entretien à Lucas Chopin regardez
bonjour Pierre Richard bonjour merci de
nous recevoir vous nous accueillez au ce
soir dans le nouvel atrium c'est le
lancement de la saison culturelle à
saint-avvertin ravi dans quelques
minutes la salle va se remplir face à
vous alors on vous a déjà vu sur les sur
les planches mais finalement question un
peu piège est-ce que le public ne se
déplace pas plus pour voir le grand
blond en vrai que pour le contenu du
spectacleah écoutez il y a un peu des
deux quand même bien sûr je n pas
qu'étant là les gens peuvent dire tiens
Onir le grand blond mais en même temps
ils sont ils auront le en prime un
orchestre de jazz qui est
formidable et qui finalement évidemment
donne au spectacle côé côté plus plus
musicau il y a il y a moi qui raconte
des histoires il y a le l'orchestre qui
qui joue du jazz qui d'ailleurs joue pas
n'importe quoi il joue les les les
musique de film et la spécialité de cet
orchestre c'est qu'il joue des musiques
de film même quand elles ne sont pas du
jazz à priori il les arrangent en jazz
donc il y a cette espèce de comme ça de
communication entre nous amusante on on
rit beaucoup d'ailleurs on rit j'espère
que les spectateur rit mais déjà nous on
rit c'est important d'être ensemble
c'est mon fils qui est un des quatre
musiciens peut-être aussi c'est ça qui
m'a qui m'a décidé à le faire ça parce
que ça m'amuse en tant que père d'être
j'ai pas souvent l'occasion d'être avec
lui sur scène il y a de la transmission
finalement il a une transmission il a
bien fait il est pas comédien comme ça
au moins on pourra pas se il pourra pas
piquer ma place mais mais en tout cas
comme j'aime le jazz et comme il aime le
jazz comme et bien voilà on est content
est tous ensemble on s'amuse bien mais
je crois que ça se ça se voit sur scène
alors c'est un mélange effectivement de
de musique le swinging à faire quartet
on réinterprète des musiques de film
vous racontez des anecdotes mais il y a
de la comédie évidemment dans tout ça
ben c'est c'est moi la comédie c'est moi
qui l'appte parce que justement comme il
joue des musiques de pas que de mes
films et la plus pas mal quand même et
moi je parle de mes souvenirs du coup
c'est un c'est un moyen de de glisser de
la musique à moi-même et moi je parle de
tous les comédiens avec qui j'ai
travaillé qui sont des comédiens
extraordinaires Jean CARM de partdieu
Jean Bernard bliet tous ces gens qui ont
que j'ai côtoyé pendant toute ma
carrière au fond jusqu'à malheureusement
certains ont disparu et comme ce sont
des gens d'un énorme talent d'une énorme
drôlerie j'ai beaucoup d'anecdotes
vraiment drôles à à à leur sujet que
avec lesquel j'ai cette chance de de
travailler sans tout nous dire vous
auriez un petit exemple je sais pas si
par die oublié non non parce que que je
le garde pour le spectacle ah c'est vrai
ah ouais il faut surtout pas que ça ça
sorte d'ici donc l'idée c'est de venir
vous voir vous voir ce soir si je
comprends bien mais faites-moi confiance
mais on vous fera confiance vous aviez
besoin de raconter de raconter ça c'est
une sorte de de bilan on peut en parler
comme ça on non pas du tout c'est
simplement il y a il y a deux raisons la
première c'est qu'encore une fois c'est
ces gens-l étaient très drôle on riait
beaucoup avant une scène on riait
beaucoup dans la scène aussi bien sûr et
on beaucoup après bon alors donc je
rappelle je donc je me remémore ça et
puis il y a des moments d'émotion bien
sûr et puis euh c'est parce que fond en
racontant tout ça je les faire vivre je
parle pas de ceux qui sont encore là
mais il y en a pas beaucoup qui sont
encore là et a Gérard et et vous voyez
je commence à buter tous les autres qui
ont été merveilleux euh des des
comédiens formidables c'est une manière
pour moi de de de raconter ces gens que
les gens ont connus et euh ils s'y
retrouveront parce que évidemment ils
les ont vu dans des multiples films et
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez plus tard
qu'on raconte de vous alors ah ben ce
sera quelqu'un un beau jour qui qui dira
je vais vous raconter pierre richchard
parce que il m'a tellement fait rire
mais allez donc savoir qui et comment et
et peut-être que ça sera jamais je sais
pas en tout cas vous êtes vous êtes là
et avec nous vous passez donc cette
soirée en Touren je sais que vous êtes
amateur de vin vous êtes le propriétaire
pour ça j'aime bien j'is vous demander
vous les aimez nos vin alors oui bien
sûr ben non Gérard on en parlait
beaucoup car aussi hein euh euh euh on
en on en parlait
beaucoup presque autant qu'on en
buvit c'est dire bon des fois on buvait
sans parler de de tout hein ça nous est
arrivait aussi hein mais bon c'està dire
qu'un Chinon ou un Bourgueil est-ce que
ça vaut un bel évêque ah là vous me
piégez parce que vous me piégez euh à
mes yeux
évidemment subjectivement j'aime mieux
le mien objectivement je vais dire que
le Chinon c'est quand même pas mal non
plus
très bien les téléspectateurs sert ravis
de de l'entendre vous êtz déjà venu
alors dans la région oui quand même
mais peut-être pas d'une manière parce
que j'ai pas tourné de film au fond moi
je connais les les les provinces de
France quand j'ai tourné des
films reste de mois hein d'ailleurs ce
qui me permet aussi de dire je connais
le Mexique parce que j'aié 3 mois au
Mexique bon c'est pas une raison pour
s'inventter parce que je 3 mois c'est
pas beaucoup mais je connais beaucoup de
pays dans le monde quand j'y reste je ne
suis pas resté à tour je vais tout faire
pour y rester ne serait-ce que pour
boire chin merci pi rich de nous avoir
accordé ces quelques minutes on vous
retrouve donc ce soir ce jeudi 12
octobre avec le swinging F quartet au
nouvel atrium de saintavvertin bonne
soirée